nos dicen considera la suma de 25 + 8 +
11 cual expresión es igual a la suma
anterior elige todas las opciones que
apliquen como siempre pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolver esto por su cuenta
cuando vemos la suma es obvio que
comenzamos en 2 agregamos 3 cada vez y
al final tenemos 4 términos en total
podríamos tratar de construir una
ecuación o una expresión para esto
usando la anotación sigma pero en lugar
de esto lo que quiero hacer es observar
las opciones que tenemos que son estas 2
y expandir las para ver cuál es la suma
que nos interesa en esta opción
comenzamos con n igual a 1 así que
tenemos 3 x 1 cuando en es igual a 1 y
le restamos 1 más y ahora pasamos a n
igualados así tenemos 3 x 2 menos uno
más ahora pasamos a n igual a 3 por lo
que tenemos 3 x 3 - 1 y finalmente
llegamos a n igual a 4 así que sumamos
tres por cuatro menos uno
para dejar claro lo que hicimos esto es
lo que obtuvimos cuando en es igual a 1
esto es lo que tenemos cuando n es igual
a 2 esto es lo que tenemos cuando en es
igual a 3 y esto es lo que tenemos
cuando en es igual a 4 nos detenemos
cuando n es igual a 4 porque aquí nos lo
indica
comenzamos con n igual a 1 y terminamos
cuando n es igual a 4 que es igual todo
esto 3 por 1 menos uno es igual a 2 que
coincide con lo que buscamos 3 x 2 menos
uno nos da 5 que sigue coincidiendo con
lo que buscamos 3 x 3 es 9 menos uno es
8 que sigue coincidiendo y al final
tenemos 3 por 4 que es 12 menos 1 es 11
todos los términos coinciden por lo que
esta es una opción correcta hagamos lo
mismo con esta otra opción cuando n es
igual a cero tenemos dos más tres por
cero lo que nos da dos cuando n es igual
a uno tenemos dos más tres por uno lo
que nos da cinco sigue coincidiendo con
lo que buscamos
esto lo obtuvimos cuando n es igual a
cero esto
lo obtuvimos cuando en es igual a 1
cuando n es igual a 2 tenemos 23 por 2
que es 8 cada vez que incrementamos n
vamos a agregar 3 unidades lo que es
consistente con lo que vimos aquí
comenzamos con n igual a 0 lo que hace
que esto sea 0 y nos quede 2 y cada vez
que incrementamos en el 1 aumentamos la
suma en 3 y finalmente cuando n es igual
a 3 2 + 3 x 3 nos va a dar 11 lo que
coincide por completo con nuestra suma
original esta opción también es correcta
hagamos otro ejemplo aquí nos dan la
suma y nos piden elegir una opción que
sea equivalente igual que hicimos en el
ejercicio anterior vamos a expandir esta
suma la diferencia aquí es que tenemos
una variable acá que no nos afecta el
proceso vamos a hacerlo veamos el caso
en el que m es igual a 1 cuando en es
igual a 1 tenemos que entre 1 + 1
anotamos que esto es cuando n es igual a
cuando en es igual a 2 tenemos cada
entre 21 esto es cuando n es igual a 2
cuando en es igual a 3 tenemos que entre
3 + 1
esto es cuando n es igual a 3 y
finalmente terminamos cuando n es igual
a 4 porque nos lo indican aquí cuando n
es igual a 4 tenemos que entre 4 1 todo
esto es igual acá entre 2 más k entre 3
más k entre 4 más acá entre 5 que es
exactamente la opción a y quizás si me
hubiera fijado primero en las opciones
me hubiera ahorrado algo de tiempo en
encontrar la respuesta ya que al
calcular el primer término que me da acá
entre 2 la única opción que coincide con
esto es la primera opción la segunda
opción no tiene casa que es bastante
raro quizá esto nos hubiera confundido
al querer reemplazar esta variable acá
con el valor de las emes en la tercera
opción no es muy obvio lo que quisieron
hacer con la k en el denominador y en la
cuarta opción si intercambiamos la k y
la
tendríamos esto de acá así que
confirmamos que elegimos la opción
correcta